en un ambiente festivo y pacífico
transcurrió la jornada de paro nacional
miles de personas salieron a las calles
de varias ciudades colombianas para
pedir cambios en las políticas del
presidente iván duque sobre la salud la
educación y la paz exigen un mayor
compromiso con el acuerdo de paz firmado
con la ex guerrilla de las farc en medio
de un aumento de asesinatos a líderes
sociales bueno esta es la gran toma de
bogotá estamos marchando por el derecho
a la vida por los acuerdos que se
cumplan pues están matando a los líderes
sociales y el gobierno no está
garantizando el derecho a la vida de
ellos las manifestaciones continúan un
reclamo social iniciado en 2019 cuando
miles de personas salieron a protestar
contra la desigualdad que ahora ha sido
acentuada por la pandemia de kobe 19 que
ubicado la tasa de desempleo en 17%
durante el mes de agosto este paro
nacional tiene su origen en el 21 de
noviembre del año pasado
se presentó por el comité nacional de
paro un pliego que el gobierno no
negoció en medio de la pandemia ante la
agudización de los problemas sociales y
laborales se presentó un nuevo pliego
nacional de emergencia que el gobierno
tampoco ha negociado en bogotá la
manifestación concluyó en la plaza de
bolívar donde se encontraba la minga
indígena un grupo originario que llegó a
la capital con la intención de conversar
con el presidente iván duque para
pedirle también seguridad en su región
que tras la desmovilización de la
guerrilla de las farc es disputada por
grupos delincuenciales follando la
colectividad la unidad porque estamos en
defender o estos territorios en los
derechos de todos los colombianos no
sólo indígenas sino todos los
colombianos
pedimos a hacer garantías para la vida
para el territorio para la democracia
luego de que el mandatario colombiano no
aceptará reunirse con ellos los
indígenas emprendieron su caravana de
regreso